how's it going guys welcome back
cmake episode three this time we're
going to be talking about sub modules
sub modules are pretty much the coolest
thing
in the world this uh combines github and
cmake to basically allow you to use
libraries from
github repositories pretty seamlessly
and cmake has the integration for that
so this is really a github thing
it's just the cmake integration board
we're also going to be talking a little
bit about options and variables because
they're going to be coming up
pretty naturally with sub modules a lot
of sub modules come with options and
variables and you often want to toggle
some of those on and off
so it's just uh it's going to flow
pretty well here all right so first
thing we're going to do is just open
the old project we had the last time so
i'm going to open
my terminal here and i'm already in the
folder as you can see
and i'm just going to do code dot to
open visual studio code with this folder
you can do it however you want
just how i'm doing and we have the old
project we've been working on there's
the
top level cmakelist.txt and
here is our little adder folder library
with
that cmakelist.txt in there and the
source all the same as before but now
we're going to add another library
except this time we're going to do it
with a sub module you can do this
basically
with anything on github just any repo
you can put any repo
into your project by well
sub moduling it in but first we're going
to have to
initialize this project with git because
this is a github feature
so we're just do get a knit on this
directory
and there we go says we have 46 changes
a ton of these changes are cmake stuff
and uh c plus plus building stuff
so the problem with this is a lot of
this stuff is not
what we want at all we wouldn't want to
push the stuff to get up so naturally we
need a git ignore is what i'm getting to
so we're going to add a dot get ignore
on our top level
and we're just going to open chrome here
and we're going to search for git ignore
4c plus plus and we'll just look at the
top result just
kind of want to get some quick answers
here to get this get ignored taken care
of
copy all that paste in the git ignore
and we're also using some cmake so we'll
look for
git ignore for cmake
and let's grab one of these quick ones
just grab this text
so this is stuff we just want github to
ignore
and we also want to of course ignore our
build folder
the one that we are using is out slash
build
uh also we want to ignore everything
called a build folder
of all capitalization styles so we'll do
it this way
cap will be or lowercase b capital u or
lowercase u
capital i or lowercase i and so on
and then the d as well
slash at the end so we just want to make
sure we ignore those build folders
and now as you can see github only sees
six pending changes
and we'll just go ahead and stage these
as init
sounds good okay so the next thing we
want to do is start adding in sub
modules and do that you go to your
terminal
and type in get sub module
add and then the repo directory and then
the folder you want it to go to
if you don't specify a folder it just
goes on the root
so we will go into chrome here
again and we're on github let's just
find a common one like glf w3 old github
so this is a just a windowing
application
none of these are it maybe it's just
called glfw
yeah here it is so this is a as it says
here
somewhere it's an open source
multi-platform library for opengl
vulkan and application development
provides a simple
platform independent api for creating
windows contacts and services reading
input handling events
so basically it handles your windowing
and events and it's cross-platform it's
very commonly used along with c plus
plus that way you can get graphics on
the screen and use something other than
the terminal
and it being cross platform super nice
because it'll work on windows
mac os linux and
maybe other things too so this is just a
great one to do an example of it also
uses cmake you can see they have a top
level
cmakelist.txt with a whole bunch of
stuff going on
so it'll just fit right in with our
project without us having to do much so
we're going to go ahead and grab this
url for the repo it's that right there
copied it all right and then we're done
here so we can minimize that
now i want to go back to my terminal and
i'll go we already have this end git sub
module add and now we got the repo and
where do we want it to go we're going to
go
to uh external
yeah we'll just call it external and
then glfw
so that'll clone it as a sub module into
external slash glfw
that way if we have multiples we can go
into external and then another name of
another library
and we can basically bring in as many
libraries as we want
i'm going to go ahead and get glf w
configured up and running so we added as
a sub module you'll see it brings in
this get modules folder
and the first thing we want to do is
actually stage these changes
this is actually really important so
we'll just say add
glsw sub module
and stage that i'm doing i'm doing it
through here but
of course you can do this through the
command line too git
commit everything that's changed and
sub module glfw
so however you want to commit with git
it's fine
you can do it through visual studio code
or you can do it through terminal
or you may have another tool don't
really want to get in to get too much
but
just know that you have to stage it
that's actually rather important or
you're going to probably get weird
errors
okay so now we can go and start setting
up our cmake list but first let's just
make sure the old version compiles
we're going to just make a few scripts
to make this easier so i'm going to do
touch configure dot sh
and touch build dot sh
touch run dot sh that way we can just
run these sh files instead of typing our
cmake over and over again
now we're also going to do ch mod plus x
to make these ch
executable i'll just make them all like
that
there we go so now we have these new sh
files
you don't have to do this you can keep
typing in cmake commands like i was
in the last time but if you're using
linux this just makes it
a little easier so first thing we want
to do is configure
and basically this is something that
will run in terminal when we run this
and our general configure is cmake
source is here and the build is
where out dot um build
so that'll just run that command that we
were running before but this time we
only have to add slash
configure and what this also does is if
we add more stuff to this
for example we're gonna add some options
for cmake here in a moment
it'll allow us to just add them to this
command here rather than having to
remember it in the terminal all the time
we just got saved in a file
and our build and this time we're going
to
change directory into alt slash build
and then just run make so that's the
terminal line we want to
actually build is just to run that make
file basically and our run
is going to be let's see we're going to
change directory to alt
slash build again and then we're just
gonna type
[Music]
okay so that should take care of all
those three files
just a little mistake here we need a
slash
right here
yeah okay you gotta get it all perfect
or else it won't be interpreted
correctly
and now that should run okay so let's go
back to our command line and now let's
try to configure
and there we go does the thing
now just as a reminder that's exactly
the same as just typing
that in the command line all right and
now let's do the build
and it builds everything as you can see
it only built the adder and the main
it did not build glfw yet and that's
because we have to configure our root
level
to add it so we need to add subdirectory
just like we did with the adder except
now it's external
slash glfw that's just the path
so now it will build it
so let's go ahead and do the configure
again since we changed it now
when it's configuring it's going through
all of glfw's stuff
as you can see it's looking for doxygen
it's looking for what display what
you know it's a cross configuration so
it's checking what platform we are
using x11 for window creation and all
that sort of thing so
pretty pretty cool there and as you can
see it's building the doxygen stuff
but if we go look at this cmakelist.txt
in glf w3 we'll see that
it has options build shared libraries
defaults to off so options are basically
just variables you can turn
on and off build documentation set to on
install set to on bulk and static set to
off
so what we can do is we can change these
at run time
or at configure time and the way you do
that is you just add it to this command
with a dash d pin the name of that
option
let me find the name of that option
again say we want to not build the docs
so we'll copy this
glw underscore build docs
go back to our cmake or our
configure the thing we're going to run
in terminal and it's dash
d i don't know why d is option you tell
me c
mac slash d and then the exact name of
that
all in as one word then equals
off so basically we're turning that
option off
because uh it defaults to on we don't
want it on we don't want to build the
documentation it's going to take up more
build time and extra space
so this is the exact same thing we just
added in this option
so that's kind of how you do options
there's a nice example
right right there yeah you can integrate
that in your product
project as needed but also yeah pretty
relevant for when you're grabbing
sub modules sometimes you don't want
every part of it so you can turn parts
off
so let's go ahead and go back into our
terminal and we'll just do the configure
again
here we go and same thing
configuring done and now let's go ahead
and build
dot sh this time it is actually
building glf w3 build target everything
else was already built
so the thing about make files
uh in in make is it doesn't build stuff
that doesn't need to be built
so since cmake is making a make file
makefile can check if things need to be
built
based on their timestamp and it only
builds what's needed you don't have to
recompile things
if they don't need recompiled so that's
just just another feature here
alright so very good we've now built it
so we'll find
in our out slash build uh
we'll see external gltw3 and we'll see a
library in here
under source it looks like and there it
is
live jltw3.a however if we want to use
this we still of course need to link it
to our
main and include it so if we just try to
do that
it's not going to work because we need
to go include
and then we need the path to it now like
we talked about last episode we need to
fix the path so we've got to add it as a
subdirectory
but we still need to go target
include directories let's just add it
so public now external gltw3
include because if we look at it
we'll see that there's an include folder
and that's what that's what you're
supposed to include
that's how a lot of open source projects
are now if these lines are getting too
long
you can kind of separate them and put
them on new lines like so a lot of
people do this when there's a ton of
them just to keep it clean
that way you can see all the included
directories in
one line each don't have to do that you
can make a big
big long one too and the same with link
directories here
we're going to need to tell it where the
link directory is so it can properly
link glfw3 we'll do this one once again
as private
and it's going to be external this link
directory is already looking in our
build folder
so it passed from here so we're going to
need to go yeah external gltw
three or not three just gl w
and then src because it's down in the
source folder
and then there it is so that's the right
path for that
so we're good there on the link
directories and now we of course need to
link the library
and it's just glf w3 as we can see here
you leave off the live part you leave
off the
a part cmake knows how to figure that
out
all it needs is this middle part
so now we have it so we can include it
easily
and we can it knows where the library is
so we can link it easily
and we're good to go we are ready to use
glf w3
so let's go ahead and use it let's go to
our main
we'll go ahead and do include glfw slash
what was the glw3.h i think
and i'll leave our old code there we'll
just pop up a window here
so it's glfw window star
window i forget all this code to be
honest so i'm going to go actually into
w3 and into examples
and in here in examples we'll just look
at any of these and let's look at gears
and let's see we have a window we have a
glove w
in it we need that init so let's add
that
and we'll just add in some more code of
course
we need this create window
uh let's see and i think we just need a
while loop basically
and terminate after the while loop has
left the building
there we go so there we go
that hole right there should
do it of course we don't have an animate
and we don't have a draw command so
of course we do need pull events and
swap buffers those are the main things
there
so there's some just very basic glfw
code this will just pop up a window
until we close it or it should
so let's go ahead and
we'll do configure then we'll do build
if we get any errors cannot find the
library so we've got something wrong
about this
linking
is it just glfw apparently i got it
on this one just yellow tell you
but apparently we don't need the three
when we're linking
i don't know that's a little weird to me
i would think that we would need it
but i must be missing something so yeah
it actually built correctly
for some reason you don't need the three
there someone can explain it that would
be great but i thought it only
when you do this i thought it only
thought about you know the live and the
dot a
i'm not sure why it's it doesn't need
that three that's uh
so now we should be able to run this and
as you can see it does pop up a window
so geoff's ob3 is working correctly all
right there we go
i will upload this and tag this version
as video three
and the link will be down below so that
way you can review
on your own time all these sh things as
i said they're totally optional
you can just you know you can run the
gui
the gui basically runs this main command
two so that's another thing i haven't
really talked about
a cmake gui it basically runs that same
command
you tell where the source code is you
tell it where you want to build
and you check you change the options as
you want it's exactly the same as doing
it in this command line
so really no difference there and that's
on windows
configure and build with
cmake using gui
using cmake gui or
use command line
linux command line easy mode i'll just
call it that
and we put four spaces i think to make
these
code type things let's see if that's
right
yeah there's just one more thing because
when you clone this project
it's not going to automatically check
out the sub modules so to make it
automatically
grab the sub modules when you start
running cmake you can actually put in
your top level cmakelist.txt
a pretty cool thing that does that okay
so one last thing i want to show you how
to use cmake
to automatically grab those repos when
it gets cloned
so that way if someone clones the
project and then tries to build it it's
not going to say
missing libraries it's just going to go
grab the libraries so normally you do
this with
git submodule
update i think and and knit
and then recursive so normally you just
do that and it gets all the sub modules
for the project
but you can put this right into your
cmake so that it does this automatically
when someone tries to build it
and uh let's see i've written that
previously in another project so i'm
just going to do some copy pasta
and then you guys can use as you want
it's uh all this right here and i'll
walk through and explain this real quick
and that will be the video
alright so before we add this
subdirectory
we want to make sure we grab the repo so
paste this here so this is a comment
just to say download all sub modules
finds the package get
make sure you have git it gets found and
your
project has a dot get folder then it
will update the sub modules so basically
this
just checks you're using github right
okay good then it continues and it has
an option here for get sub module that
defaults to on
so this is another option you could turn
off if you don't want it to grab the sub
modules
but if it's on which is default stone
it's just going to go
hey it's going to give you a message so
this is another thing you can do i
haven't talked about yet as it's running
you saw those messages in the command
line you can put your own custom ones in
with this here so you can kind of tell
the user what's going on
now we have an execute process i haven't
talked about execute process either
this basically just runs a command of
your choice
so it makes cmake even more versatile
because you can run
commands uh directly from it so this
will run
let's see that you get executable of
course just get and it's going to run
sub module update and then recursive
which is that same thing i just talked
to uh typed in and then it's going to
save a few things it's going to do it in
the working directory and it's going to
re
save the result as get submodule result
and that allows it to do a check
afterwards
to make sure it's not false so when it
gives a fatal error if it was false and
it will say
failed so that way it just has a little
check
so this block right here just basically
downloads all your sub modules
and then afterwards we're just going to
make sure that glfw
cmakelist.txt exists just
want to do that before you start adding
it as a subdirectory
so it's just going to check if not exist
fatal error so it'll quit right there on
a fatal error if
it doesn't exist otherwise it's going to
continue and add the subdirectory so
it's nice to have this in here that way
when someone else grabs your project
and it relies on sub modules it'll just
download all the sub modules
pretty cool thing and that's it i'll go
ahead and save that
the add sub module pull down
stage that to the cmake and
go ahead and push that and now i can
push this
but as you can see it has no remotes
i'll post i'll add the remote and
post it down below that way you guys can
check out all the source code
at the end thanks for tuning in hope you
guys are able to
use cmake and uh you know help
help master level your projects get them
to the
get them to where it's easier to work
with is really
the goal but this is all making sense
let me know if you have any questions
down below
and i will see you guys in the next
episode
peace out
you